hey guys it's justine and i'm at condo
3.0 i'm actually filming this video at
the end of the event but it is such an
amazing inspiring few days that i got a
chance to spend with
really amazing creators and
photographers and behind me the moon
is rising over the mountains it is
absolutely beautiful we're in bend
oregon and we're at this place called
sun river
and it has been such a fun few days so
i'm gonna show you guys some vlog
footage here that i filmed with the
rx100 mark 7.
and right now i've got my favorite setup
i've got the microphone just plugged in
directly to the camera we also got a
chance to check out the sony a7r
iv and it is also absolutely incredible
we shot some really cool photos with
that
so i'll share some of those with you
here as well if you want to see nori
nori hi nori nori is the queen of condo
nori nori are you eating grass
we're about to get the best tracking
shot ever of jen and i
riding these bikes curtis you guys may
remember
we did the moon live stream that one day
dude we're getting weird out here in
oregon you know
yeah this is crazy we're shooting with
some great technology
this thing is insane yeah so it's
basically a uh
six axis stabilized gimbal you can
stabilize up to a thousand millimeter
lens
yeah and you can track from the ground
from a boat from the helicopter or
whatever
just like it makes it kind of unfair
it's like the lazy
but you drove this from la right yeah
it's great
today we are going to track some very
quality content jen and i
riding these bicycles of course
compliments
of bnh with the bnh flag focus right
here
and then you have your zoom right there
a lot of times when people operate you
kind of have your thumb resting on the
zoom rocker
it's pretty cool i'm going to be
controlling the shot over jenna is going
to be behind me
and i'm going to be attempting to follow
her and
pull focus and zoom all the same time do
you think i could do it um
yeah she's got it cool all right here
i'll be your filmmaker okay
oh this is incredible so where did jenna
go
there's a lot going on there you gotta
kind of you know yeah
we'll give you the crash course and shot
over i already got it i'm good i'm ready
all right good
sweet all right send it oh my gosh this
is the coolest go
ever at it we got a big old gimbal there
stable as it gets who that talent that's
some talent right there
justine here on the sticks yeah my focus
though i'm not really good at focusing
well you better get get it
[Music]
oh yeah this is like pretty legit
actually
[Music]
so what do you think what happened okay
number one got a little motion sickness
but number two this was so much fun i
mean basically it felt like i was
playing a real life video game like
tracking jenna
it was really fun but i look cool i
can't wait to look at my footage my only
problem is the focus it's really hard to
pull focus
and you know you're moving around and
there's a lot of stuff happening you did
a pretty good job though
thank you well let me tell you what
everyone was super impressed they're
like what is that
but they were not impressed with the
subject matter like they're tracking her
[Music]
while in bend oregon you have to go to
the last blockbuster this is the last
one
open ever anywhere and we're here i
don't know what we're gonna do probably
gonna buy some water because i'm really
thirsty
and we can't buy something to return
because we want to live here
we'll return it yeah but you buy stuff
here right i don't know we're gonna find
out though we're gonna go in
no public restrooms available that's for
sure there it is could you take my
photograph
i would like to take a picture of me
watching a youtube video
in front of the blog
[Music]
hello i used to come and wrap movies
with my family like all the time oh my
god it is my favorite movie ever you
guys are probably think i'm weird but
this is one of my favorite movies ever
if you haven't seen it uh i don't know i
wouldn't recommend it
do you feel like you're in the 90s or i
don't know man
another one of my favorite movies
definitely time traveled
it looks like they have t-shirts and
stuff for sale so like they probably
sell more t-shirts
than movies here definitely a time
travel there was
blockbuster and now we go we're heading
back we're gonna get dinner and i think
there's some other activities
jenna wants to go do a night shoot
there's so much stuff there's so much to
do i'm overwhelmed
so right now we're shooting a little
behind the scenes video here of making
another cool animation i'll put a link
right here to the instagram
this is our second try spoiler
[Music]
got the shot
hi it is so early but we are going on
like a four mile hike it's
some smith rocks or something it's a
state park
and we're going super early so that we
can be back for all of the condo
activities i don't even think i slept
last night
like at all it's still night time
we have to get coffee and waters i've
got my sat phone
i've got my rx100 mark 7. i've got extra
batteries we do have to go
[Music]
we are not even a minute into this hike
yet we're not even out of the parking
lot
it's so beautiful i didn't bring the a7r
iv because i didn't want to carry it
so i said i'm only bringing what i can
carry but like i could have left it in
the car
i have mine but i had all the lenses oh
you did have all the
this looks to me like we go shoot trail
200 mil zoom pretty far
we're not even a mile in yet just so you
know
how many miles like four four mile loop
the whole first part of this is around
the river
he has a little smudgy so we entered
this hike i got nervous because i saw a
bunch of rock climbers i was like crap
do we have to like climb
[Music]
the rx100 what i love about it is it
will automatically orientate your videos
if you start shooting vertically
it'll know that you're shooting
vertically and it prepares the video for
you
to post on instagram stories that's
great i
know look how pretty this is look at
that vertical video lifestyle
[Music]
why does that say most difficult i've
never seen that before me either this
was rated
moderate
we're on it now so here we go
what i found from all trails is their
definition of moderate
it's not the same definition that i have
it is called misery called i mean
look at that this looks like a face
we just passed the people that were rock
climbing they climbed up and over the
mountain now they're going down
so they definitely made way better time
than we're making it was like
[Music]
made it to the top i thought it was
actually going to be way more difficult
i mean going up this part was pretty
strenuous
but i thought it went up for a lot
further now that we're here there's the
little face that we saw
we went all the way around the mountain
from over here around here
up here's a 360 shot over the ledge
yeah i'm not getting any closer don't
look down
yes we do the water
cause we have different dreams
apparently there's another ridge and we
just made it there we're on our way down
now
and it is just like the coolest views
it's really awesome it's way cooler than
i thought
[Music]
i'd like to save it again
i want you
right now we are shooting something
super exciting with this really cool
location
and we're shooting carson doing some
really crazy bmx tricks we've got the
drone
curtis has his shot over which you guys
saw me use previously jenna has the a7r4
you got that 400 on there 100 400 to 400
there's a lot going on okay time to fly
[Music]
[Applause]
circle good morning good morning good
morning
it's early we're going to go find the
sunrise
do not enter i don't know
don't do it don't do it don't do it no
it's super confusing we have
we have heard all right jason
it's so dark it's a really great backlit
we'll see them in a second when the sun
rises okay so we made it here
we have to be quiet because there's
people camping all around us
[Music]
it's beautiful it's so pretty
did
[Music]
uh i'm going to be the motor you're
going to be the navigator
you're just leaning forward so should i
put it on
no you don't have oregon state law just
make sure but like should i
no it's all flat waters okay there's no
rapids but like how deep is it
um it is over your head we'll load you
up and get you back up here news
high chance
i forgot my apple watch nothing counts
for activity today
it's unfortunate
oh my gosh his face this is so cute
[Music]
our friend farook who you've seen in my
videos before he just hit 500 000
subscribers on youtube here at condo so
we decided we're going to get him a cake
we asked them to write
congrats on 500k iphonedo
well that's not quite how they
interpreted it
it says congrats on book but i'm gonna
fix it
i've been thinking about this for the
past hour and a half how i can do this
congrats on
[Music]
in oh my gosh it looks perfect i know
just does somebody need a ride
yes i need a ride get in
all right i have a problem i travel a
lot i always buy bananas but i never end
up finishing them so this morning i got
a banana and then i left it oh my gosh
it has turned it has baked it's
fermented
i mean this is rotten it's disgusting
should we do an unboxing
um is it squishy oh my god it's so
squishy just put it back quickly it like
blended it i didn't even see it i
thought it was my sunglass case
baroque surprise okay you go this way
this way oh my god
yes
yeah yeah hug it out chug it out
i just said an iphone for you pretty
even good job
well thank you guys so much for watching
i hope you enjoyed this video i had the
best time and i hope you guys enjoyed
some of the footage from the rx 100 mark
7 and i will see you guys in my next
video
bye
hi nori